[MUSIC]
By using the Elsa model.
So you want to create some events
inside of your organization.
This doesn't require a lot
of permission seeking.
What this requires is really
an understanding for the problem.
Some small scale experiments to try to
solve the problem and then some data
that you can share and so I love this
because it uses the model in the small.
You create a small event you
have some language around it and
you deliver that that event
back into your organization and
this will start to affect the structure.
I guarantee you if you lead
with the language of change.
The structure will not give way.
So it's very very hard to get the kind
of agency that you that need to do
the whole thing when you haven't
started with even the very basics.
So oftentimes people feel when they
share this the first response is,
man I've got to do something.
What I really want to do is
I want to convince people.
I want to get them to
change their attitude.
Well, attitude changes is good,
but it's hard.
And it's maybe the least effective
in terms of how we can change
how we can move behavior.
So my favorite example of this is I
wanted to become a marathon runner.
So I went out and I bought the shoes and
I bought the outfit and
I really developed this strong
attitude that I'm going to be awesome.
And then I sat on the couch and
I ate Lucky Charms and
I watched a lot of marathons in my
new shoes and my new running outfit.
What changed was my attitude but
what didn't change was my behavior.
And so
the event helps to shape two things.
It provides language
to talk about it but
it actually gives us a vision of what
good looks like and it gets us started.
I think it's BJ Fogg
who talks about this,
if you want to be a runner,
you need to hire a running coach.
You might need shoes too, like you might
need a cool outfit, but the first thing
you do is you need someone who's
going to show up at your house.
And take you running and I think the
same idea works inside the organization.
Find some small area of
improvement that you can do.
Do it and then share that
result with the organization.
I wouldn't go big or
broad and I wouldn't spend a lot
of time trying to convince.